-They love you.
We love you. Welcome back.
Congrats. July 4th.
I'm excited about the premiere.
-Yeah.
-It's good to hang
with you guys.
-Good to be back.
-I'm happy you are back.
And Sadie,
I've never met you.
-Yeah, it's my first time here.
-Nice to meet you.
-Yeah, nice to meet you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's talk about
the new season,
and things that
we can tell people
that isn't
spoiling anything.
I know a lot of it was shot
in a mall.
-Yeah.
Was it a real mall?
-It was a real mall, actually.
-It was?
-It was, yeah.
It was, like, this mall --
-A working mall?
-It was, actually.
-Technically.
-It is, still, actually.
-It was a little haunted.
-A little bit.
-Every time we'd be in there,
it'd be fine.
And then, we'd all just kind of
look at each other, and be like,
"Something wrong
with this mall."
[ Laughter ]
And it kind of helped.
-Yeah.
-The thing is,
it's still operational.
Even though they, like, bought,
like, a piece of the mall,
and, like,
they redid it totally...
-It's incredible.
-Like, a whole --
It looks gorgeous.
It's amazing.
I think people
still go there, now.
-Yeah.
-And just, like, look around.
But, like --
-Well, how much fun is that,
to be in an empty mall?
-It's so cool.
But it's not even empty.
-So fun.
-Like, a bunch of people are
shopping as we're filming.
in the mall, people are shopping
as we're filming.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-And, like,
I see people just like...
[ Laughter ]
...looking in.
Like...
Serious, like,
spoilers happening.
Like, major plot points.
-Don't tweet this!
Don't tweet this!
-But, like,
serious plot points.
They're just looking.
They're like, "Huh."
-'Cause it's, like,
an active --
sometimes, our trailers
are in active parking lots.
And so, someone will just
drive in and be like,
"Is this the Keith Urban
concert?"
[ Laughter ]
And they'll
just be like --
And they'll just
be like,
"No. This is a working set."
And they're like,
"Alright."
And they roll up --
They don't even care.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-Yeah, I guess.
-But I heard that you --
you would actually go
up and down the escalators...
-Yeah.
-...as slides.
-That was my idea.
-That was your idea?
-Bad idea.
-Oh, it was a bad idea?
-Great, good i--
bad, good idea, whatever.
-It was a great idea.
-Well, like, the ADs and stuff
that were in charge of us,
they would say
it was a bad idea.
-The space in between...
-The escalator.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
He started sliding down it.
Then, we all did.
And then, the production team
hated us for it.
-Yeah.
-But, no, went went against --
-I moved the
barrier cones
-Yeah.
-They put cones,
but then,
we moved the cones.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-It was a giant slide. 'Cause
usually, they have, like...
-Little things stopping you.
-...the little things
stopping you.
They didn't have that.
-No, they didn't.
But then, at the end,
they did.
-And it was, like, greasy.
-Yeah.
It was.
-But what was cool is that,
we kept doing it.
They told us to stop.
So, we stopped for, like,
a couple weeks.
And then, we started
doing it again, 'cause...
-I didn't stop.
-You didn't stop.
-I kept going.
-He never stopped, no.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-I forget who it was
who suggested it,
but, like, everyone's like,
"No. Stop."
And then, all of a sudden,
they're like,
"Hey. Slide down that
for the shot."
-It was Maya.
It was Maya.
-Well, I mean,
Maya suggested it,
but, like, everyone was,
like, super down with it
except for the ADs.
-Oh, of course.
-The ADs were like,
"Do not slide down that.
It's dangerous."
-I distinctly
remember Caleb --
someone going, "Caleb,
please do not slide down it."
And him just going...
-Oh, wow.
-While giving this
straight face, he's like...
-They hated you for that.
[ Laughter ]
-And then,
I just slide down.
-It seems like you guys,
like, bonded so much
on all these seasons.
I mean,
it's kind of fun,
because it's, like,
really, I could feel --
-Specifically over disobeying.
-Yeah. Exactly. Of course.
Yeah. Did you -
You came in last season,
but do you feel like
you're part of
the family now?
-Yeah.
I feel like I am.
I think I fit in okay,
I guess.
-You definitely are. I mean,
I know you guys get together,
and just joking backstage,
we were all just --
there's always, like,
10 bits going on.
Someone's doing a bit,
and then, someone's laughing
at some other bit. And then,
someone's singing a song.
What is this song
that you invented?
Caleb, you.
-Oh.
Another invention of mine.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-Do you think you
invented sliding?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. He invented sliding.
-Technically, on our set,
you invented sliding.
-On our set.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-What's the song?
-"Chicken Noodle Soup."
It's a song that I made
to annoy Gaten and Sadie.
-It works.
-It definitely works.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-And then, you started barking,
and annoying us.
-They didn't like it,
but then, they joined in.
-Then, we joined in.
-Yeah.
-Do you want to hear it?
-I would like to.
What does it sound like?
What is the name
of the song?
-"Chicken Noodle Soup."
-And it's annoying?
-Oh, God.
-Yeah. It was just a song
to annoy them.
You guys ready?
-Ready.
-Ready?
One, two...
-Three.
-♪ Chicken noodle soup ♪
♪ I feel good
when you're around ♪
-Oh, God.
-♪ Chicken noodle soup ♪
-That's on key, Roots.
-♪ ...when I'm down ♪
♪ Chicken noodle soup ♪
♪ I feel good
when you're around ♪
♪ Chicken noodle soup ♪
♪ [Indistinct] ♪
♪ When I'm down ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's just a beautiful...
-I know.
-That's just a beautiful,
beautiful song.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-I feel like I'm at
a Keith Urban concert.
-No, no,
that's one parking lot down.
How would you explain
the new season?
Again, I'm just so
excited about that.
Netflix, by the way,
did not sneak me any episodes,
which, normally, I get...
-Which is so rude.
-Right?
I mean, Netflix,
I can keep a secret
better than anyone.
-Uh...
[ Indistinct talking ]
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, Millie,
how's your toe?
-Oh, my Go--
[ Laughs ]
-What?
-Last time I was here,
Jimmy stepped on my toe,
trying to sabotage me.
-No, I did not. I did not.
-Yeah, you did.
Don't deny it.
-[Indistinct]...choreographed
a dance.
-On the plane after,
I was, like, icing.
No.
-No, I stepped back,
and I'm like, "Ooh."
And then, I was like --
-And then, I, like,
looked at you,
and I was like...
I still engaged
with the Roots.
I was like,
"Guys, bring it back up for me."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And all of a sudden,
boom, my toe, like...
-But it's
recovering now?
-Yeah, it's recovering.
It's slowly recovering.
We'll see.
-Without giving away spoilers,
can we sum up, maybe,
the new season
in one word?
I thought you
could do that,
and that wouldn't
give anything away.
And we could start with Finn,
and go all the way down.
Can you sum up the new season
in one word?
-Classic.
Does that make sense?
-Yeah.
-Caleb?
-Um, you know, gory, prob--
yeah, gory.
-Sadie?
-Fun.
-That's wildly different
from Caleb's answer.
Gory and fun.
-Finn is doing more
than one word.
-Uh...
spreading.
-What?
-Spreading?
-Spreading.
-It makes sense -- It makes
sense once you see it.
-You guys know
what it means.
-No.
-Yes, you do.
-It makes sense
once you see it.
-I have no clue
what you're talking about.
-Okay, alright,
spreading.
-Sad.
-Oh.
-Wow!
Wow!
What a reaction "sad" got!
It's so sad.
-I said "gory."
That's pretty sad, guys.
-Yeah.
"Classic" -- "Classic"
and "gory" are off the table.
But "sad" --
now, you've got me.
[ Laughter ]
-Bigger.
-Oh.
[ Indistinct talking ]